- So I got a really funny comment
on Twitter that I think is worth sharing.
By the way, the handle on
Twitter is now @legaleagle.
I got the main handle on Twitter,
I think that's great.
But here's the comment I got.
If I've learned anything
from Legal Eagle it's to
not email anyone ever.
Yeah so I would never tell
you to do anything illegal,
but if you are going to
do something illegal,
you should not put it in an email
or in the case of Matt gates, don't put it
in your Venmo history.
The bread and butter of litigation
these days is calling
over hundreds of thousands
of electronic documents,
whether it's emails or files
on the computer and the
documents don't tend to lie.
So yeah, if you're worried
about committing some sort
of crime, don't put it in an
email or I'll see you in court.